just to make sure that you know you just
said you're Republican advocating to the
Republican Party to fall apart well I
think over time that's what has to
happen I think both parties not just the
Republican Party I think the Democratic
Party as well if you ask the average
libertarian who their favorite
congressman is chances are they'll say
the name Justin Amash which may prove
fortunate for him because Amash is
sounding less Republican by the day as a
critic of executive power and champion
of constitutionalism the Grand Rapids
native has become a leading thorn in the
side of Donald Trump serving is one of
only two GOP co-sponsors of a bill
calling for an independent investigative
Commission into the president's
russia-related behavior frequently
calling out the administration on social
media and finding himself on the
receiving end of a white house call to
get primary reason caught up with Amash
at Freedom Fest in Las Vegas and the
congressman wasted no time distancing
himself from his own political party and
I'm joined today by the great
libertarian leaning Republican
congressman from Michigan Justin Amash
congressman thank you for joining us so
libertarian is fine yeah okay you're
already of ending it they're going rogue
so we're recording this on Friday
afternoon a lot of stuff has happened in
the last 36 hours in Washington having
to do with President Donald Trump he
gave an interview with the New York
Times in which he said if he had to do
it all over again he wouldn't hire Jeff
Sessions because Jeff Sessions recused
himself Russian investigations he called
into question the integrity of a lot of
people the Justice Department kicked the
tires on potential pardons for his kids
or other people in the administration
and and generally is starting to put
pressure on the special counsel Robert
Miller and don't get too far out of your
lanes and this type of stuff as someone
who co-sponsored one of the two
Republican co-sponsors if I know this
right of a bill in Congress to
investigate other precedents or set up a
special commission what's just your
general reaction to this behavior over
the last 36 hours it's typical it's not
anything new so didn't surprise me and I
think that the president
doesn't really understand how the
justice department works and that he
really needs to keep some distance from
these investigations but you know it's
Donald Trump then he's going to do what
he's going to do what if he fires Robert
Muller if he pre pardons somebody close
to him is that a constitutional crisis I
don't know I don't know the history on
pardons and whether that would be a
major problem constitutionally but the
president has a lot of authority to fire
people within the executive branch so
setting aside the constitutional
concerns because I think you can at
least make some arguments I don't know
whether they hold water setting aside
the constitutional concerns there are
ethical concerns there are a rule of law
concerns so we want to make sure that
when a president is in the White House
that he's living up to all the ethical
standards that he is allowing the system
of Justice to work itself out the way
it's supposed to work without
interference and there are those
concerns so I don't want to go the
constitutional route yet on this kind of
thing but certainly there are a rule of
law and ethics concerns if he does do
something like that is the is there a
that kick in to remedy should there be
some action that hasn't been taken so
far taken as a result of that well there
are always political consequences so
polling numbers will change if people
think that the president can't be
trusted
there are those political realities and
you'll have more and more Republicans
who are uncomfortable with the way the
White House is operating so I think over
time that's probably what will have the
biggest impact here whether it will
impact the president's behavior over the
next few years I don't know but it might
have an impact over the next election
cycle you have one of the great Twitter
feeds out there in Congress and a week
or two ago you tweeted something along
the lines of you know having principles
is better than just resorting to what
about ISM all the time do you see a lot
of what about ISM happening from your
caucus these days when it comes to
treating with and reacting to actions of
press and Trump yeah it's not just from
in Congress Democrats in Congress do
this too and and so does the general
public I think we should be concerned
about hypocrisy where one side is doing
something we think it's okay and on the
other side does something and we think
it's bad so there are reasonable
concerns about hypocrisy but that
doesn't mean that every time President
Trump or Republicans do something we
should just say well the Democrats did
the same thing because there's no
accountability then at some point people
have to decide to make the change
themselves they can't always blame the
other side and say well the other side
did the same thing that's how you get
these third-world despotic systems where
everyone says well the other side does
it so we just want our strongman to beat
up on on them when when he's in power
and you see that all around the world
then as well other places where people's
rights are restricted on the basis of we
are guys in power now we should do the
same thing that they did to us do you
feel like the Republican caucus in
particular has been exercised someone
you're a critic of congressional
inaction and abdicating its
responsibility do you feel like Congress
has been been doing well in its
oversight responsibility of the
executive branch under President Trump
not so well just right or what's what's
your assessment of that so far not so
well the number of committee hearings
has dropped significantly when you have
the Obama administration in charge you
had a lot of Republicans making sure
that we are investigating every little
detail and now you don't have that as
much and you certainly have many members
who are concerned about what's going on
but you don't have to the same degree
and that's not to say that in any
particular situation the president is
necessarily doing something wrong right
but we always have to stay on top of
things as a Congress that's part of our
role to have oversight and I think it's
good for everyone if we oversee the
executive branch and find that nothing
was wrong in a particular situation
that's better for everyone it's better
for Republicans it's better for
Democrats it's better for the country
let's talk a little bit about other ways
that Congress advocates its
responsibilities this week if I'm not
mistaken the authorization for use of
military force was in play as part of
the Defense Authorization Act and it
kind of vanished overnight what happened
there what's the status of that yeah it
was in a defense appropriations bill and
then it was seemingly stripped out so
the idea was to restrict the government
from using that old authorization from
for use of military force on whatever
they want today so there's a lot of
pressure in Congress on leadership to do
something new to put a new authorization
in place if we want to go after Isis if
we want to do things in Syria and Yemen
and other places there should be a new
authorization it doesn't make sense now
so many years later a decade and a half
later to be using the same authorization
as though we are fighting the same war
it's a different group of actors the
people we're fighting today aren't the
same people who perpetrated the 9/11
attacks so if we want to continue that
fight let's get a new authorization with
appropriate limitations and I think that
there should always be a time limitation
on authorization so that there's there
should be a requirement that they have
to be reauthorized at some point that
doesn't mean you're telling the enemy
when the war is going to end it just
means that Congress has to do its job
and say if this battle is continuing we
have to have another authorization was
this as close as we've come since 2001
to actually reaping and requiring the
wreckage of the authorization of use of
military force and what happened to it
what was the process by which had
vanished yeah it was the closest we've
been allegedly it was allowed on there
by the chairman of the committee without
the blessing of Republican leadership
without the blessing of the White House
and so I think whether it was the White
House or House leaders they came in and
said we're stripping this out we don't
think this is an appropriate venue and
and my understanding is they're putting
a different provision in there
in the in the bill so that we can do a
watered down version of what was there
from representative Lee I let's talk
more about Congress here obviously
Obamacare repeal replace or whatever
we're calling it revamp retooling has
been and the failure there rob has been
on everyone's lips you were part of the
both the original House defeat of that
bill and then also the narrow victory of
its replacements and changes of some of
the language of it just first for
anything else the bill that was that
didn't get put to floor didn't the
motion to proceed failed Mike Lee and
others Rand Paul blocked it that bill if
it had been passed and gotten to you
back would you have voted yes or no I
didn't read it so I was the body of the
bills so I can't tell you what what I
would have done there were a lot of
things I heard about that we're
concerning but I decided that it wasn't
in my interest to read it at this point
because I've got a lot of other things
on my plate and I wasn't sure the Senate
was going to get it through anyways so
so I start reading that bill and then it
doesn't pass I got to read a whole
nother bill is it your understanding
that there would have been and there
would be in the future in case anything
passes which I don't think is
particularly likely that there would be
a conference committee and there would
be actual negotiations there or would be
kind of an up or down take it or leave
it situation it's not clear house
freedom caucus members have called for a
conference committee because we suspect
that whatever comes out of the Senate
will be worse than what came out of the
house so we think it would be a good
idea to have a conference committee but
I'm not 100% sure I mean I don't know
what's going to come out of the Senate
at this point if anything and whether we
have an up or down vote or a conference
committee that's almost for sure going
to be a political decision by leadership
it's not going to be based on policy and
just to display my own parliamentary
ignorance here if the house freedom
caucus were to say we're going to hold
our breath and turn blue in the face
unless we get a conference committee do
they have that power I think we can find
some procedural tools to block it if we
if we have to it will be challenging but
we can talk to the parliamentarian and
figure out a way to stop something bad
from pass
to the house and as you know the the
House version of the bill wasn't very
good in itself I mean that wood that
bill had plenty of problems but I
thought it was marginally better than
Obamacare very marginally so if the
Senate bill is any worse than the House
bill it's it's in trouble and it's
marginally better and also passed by a
margin passed by four votes yeah which
is slim margin two people who can who
can flip at the time I was critical of
the house freedom caucus and I know some
of the people who work for leadership
there are unhappy with the way that I
characterized the the turning of events
there eats shorthand TV you say things
like Donald Trump put a lot of pressure
on mark meadows and they change their
mind they say it's overly simplistic so
can you correct my misapprehension mark
Meadows the chair of the house freedom
caucus has had quotes along the lines of
hey when the president calls you and
then the vice president calls you and
says get a bill done you're going to
work to get a bill done and I take that
perhaps naively as maybe the president
is putting a lot of pressure on people
who don't like to feel pressure and
that's affecting their moods am I am I
being too cruel in my assessment here
mark Meadows is a Southern gentleman
and he tries to present things in a way
that I think are not going to be too
upsetting to the White House or to
leadership he's doing his job as the
chairman of trying to work with everyone
I think that it wasn't pressure from the
White House or pressure from leadership
it was that we had put together an
amendment that we thought would
marginally improve the bill make it
better than Obamacare and when that was
sufficiently supported we had the group
move in that direction and move on board
with that with that amendment but it
wasn't pressure from the White House or
leadership your friend Thomas Massie
who's a just like you except even more I
described all of this as the equivalent
of some kind of hot potato or everyone
knew that the next guy was going to be
the one to block this from happening is
that how do you respond to that kind of
characterization of a bill that not many
actual
policy analysts from the libertarian or
conservative point of view like I have
to get basically one liked it and it's
hysterically and historically unpopular
was there a feel and you know actually a
lot of your colleagues like Mark Sanford
when talking about why you voted yes
it's like well let's keep the discussion
going which is almost looks saying you
know I don't want it to stop on my watch
let's have conversations later was there
an element to let's just kind of keep
putting off d-day on this thing for some
people I think that was true that they
want to just move it along
from my perspective when you look at a
piece of legislation you see doesn't
move us marginally in the right
direction and if it does you vote for it
the other stuff is very hard to predict
all of the long term strategy isn't
going to come back how is it going to
look so you have to look at that piece
of legislation and really focus on does
it improve things marginally and I
thought it did and I agree with your
assessment and others assessment that
it's not a good piece of legislation
just like Obamacare is terrible but if
it's marginally better than Obamacare
that's what you do and and every member
of Congress does that even the people
who were concerned about this piece of
legislation on other bills they'll tell
you oh we're moving it along marginally
so they support those bills in all sorts
of other areas I mean what people doing
from 2010 to 2017 this is it like like
there's a lot of politics around
Obamacare so very successful politics I
might add what is it that people weren't
doing the policy work and the actual
harder political work of working with
your own colleagues from your own party
and hashing out the you know the huge
chasm between the Rand Paul's and
Suzanne Collins's of the world what what
happened why was this such a kind of oh
hey it's November 9th 2016 what are we
going to do about this thing that we've
been talking about for six years there
was a lot of policy work there were a
lot of proposals out there a lot of
ideas and and some of those were
incorporated into the bill I think
Republicans made a strategic mistake
years ago when they started talking
about repeal and replace and keeping
particular provisions from Obamacare if
you start to talk about keep
this provision or that provision you end
up having to keep a whole bunch of other
stuff or just restructure restructuring
it in a way that essentially keeps the
same bill in place so I always thought
it was a mistake to talk about keeping
the particular pre-existing conditions
provisions or the particular provisions
on community ratings or regulations
there are ways to address those concerns
for people who have pre-existing
conditions there are ways to address
that but to say that you're going to
keep it the way it is that was a mistake
so when when the bill came to the floor
when we had this this new bill
comfortable come to the floor it was
inevitable that was going to keep a lot
of Obamacare in place because too many
promises were made by Republicans and I
think a lot of Republicans also didn't
think that we would have the white house
and didn't see an opportunity that would
come along in the near future to repeal
Obamacare so they made these promises
that they're going to repeal it and they
made other promises that they're going
to keep parts of it if if push comes to
shove and now they're in this dilemma
where they want to keep parts of it but
keeping parts of it means essentially
keeping most of Obamacare in place and
their promise to repeal is has been
shown to be not a true promise not
something that they ever intended to
really follow through on
I want to repeal Obamacare and still
support a full repeal of Obamacare I
think we should start over we should
repeal Obamacare and this is something
that should be handled at the state
level Jeff Sessions Train general this
week expanded rollback very modest
reforms have been made under Eric Holder
about civil asset forfeiture which is
legalized theft by cops to put it my
spin on it at least you've been a big
critic of that I think you have a bill
introduced to do something about that
talk a little bit just about a first
year reaction to that and one of the
prospects that Congress will react to
what is a very unpopular practice to the
extent that Americans know about this
they hate it and rightfully so is there
actual possibility for Congress to act
in a corrective way to this yeah so
Senator Paul has though right now I'm
working on something that is more
comprehensive his bill reforms civil
asset forfeiture in a way that I think
is positive and moves us in the right
direction but I'd like to see something
more comprehensive I'd like to wipe out
civil asset forfeiture at the federal
level and at the state level so my
office is currently drafting legislation
it's taken a while because there's a lot
of parts of the code that you have to
work through so we're going to get that
legislation out hopefully in the near
future but there's a lot of public
support for getting rid of civil asset
forfeiture it's unconstitutional it's
the idea that the government can come in
and take your property without due
process and a lot of people I think
we're unaware of it or just starting to
learn about it people on the left and
the right there are people on the Left
who don't like the Trump administration
so that now they're hearing about it all
but all of a sudden but actually this
was the policy under Democratic
presidents as well so the letter Lynch
was not particularly fond of the
practice yeah Loretta Lynch love the
idea of civil asset forfeiture and I've
criticized her for that on Twitter and
elsewhere in the past so this is a
bipartisan issue it's something that all
Americans should be concerned about we
believe in due process in this country
but we believe that your property should
it be taken away without some kind of
criminal conviction and right now the
practice in this country is to allow the
government to take your stuff without
convicting you of anything
and in fact without even charging you
with a crime so it's it's pretty
outrageous and I think most conservative
and libertarian commentators out there
are saying this and pointing it out to
people so I think we'll have some
momentum on this so you're going to wipe
it out of the state level - you're going
to make it a federal crime to do this or
well the there's a 14th amendment that
protects due process at the state level
doesn't allow the state to do these
kinds of things either so our
Constitution allows us to draft
legislation at the federal level that
would restrict the state's ability to
violate people due process what else
have you seen from attorney general
sessions that has set off your alarm
bells everything I mean the whether it's
indefinite detention there's a whole
host of things out there the the drug
war his belief that we should continue
to prosecute people for minor drug
offenses but at the same time those are
things that Congress has a duty to
change so we don't like the way the law
is being enforced if we think that Jeff
sessions should spend his time on more
important matters then we have a
responsibility to change the law so
let's change the law let's change the
law in civil asset forfeiture let's
change the law on sentencing let's
change the law on indefinite detention
let's change all these laws and then
there's no excuse for the Attorney
General to do the wrong thing
Eximbank it's a live listen we've been
talking about you know a criminal
justice reform for three or four years
and a lot of like sort of surveillance
post Snowden revelation reform and all
these kinds of things with the Exim Bank
was was euthanized for like a week and a
half at some point and it seems to be
rising up I talked to me that
specifically well what what you're
trying to do with was murdering that
that crony capitalist thing in its sleep
one more time but like what why can't
Republicans do even like Republican
things right I've been asking myself
that question for a long time but the
export-import bank is a no brainer it's
a corporate welfare Bank we should do
away with it I've had legislation over
the past couple terms to get rid of the
export-import bank to phase it out so
it's actually a pretty modest piece of
legislation it gives them a little bit
of time to face things out but the
export-import bank should go away
we shouldn't be financing other
countries to purchase stuff from big
corporations in the United States that's
just a transfer of wealth from everyday
Americans to these big companies and
they'll say to you that oh it doesn't
cost anything but taxpayers are on the
hook so if you used normal accounting
principles you see that taxpayers are on
the hook for the liability here and
we have a major problem that has to be
addressed
so let's get rid of it and in many ways
it's a symbol of other types of
corporate welfare at the federal level
and at the state level so let's get rid
of it because I think it's a it's a
pretty easy target it's a it's a target
that's right in front of us and they
don't have the number of board members
necessary right now to operate it hasn't
been operating really the way it's
traditionally operated for the last two
years because of the lack of board
members and the world doesn't fall apart
falling apart Boeing still exists all
these other companies are are still
doing just fine
so we can do away with it and and help
out regular Americans they'll tell you
as well that small businesses benefit
from this but actually it's a very small
percentage of businesses that benefit
from this so we're talking about a
fraction of a percent and all of these
people are essentially paying taxes
whether it's small businesses or
individuals or paying taxes to help
support something like the export-import
bank but very few get any benefits from
it starting with the Ron Paul's runs for
presidency which I think helped at least
partially inspire you and the Tea Party
movement of 2009 and 2010 there was this
kind of creation out of out of the ether
of Liberty movements and it felt like
there's momentum going in this direction
on the ex-im bank and other things we've
talked about elsewhere and now we have a
you know a president and a movement
around him that's pretty national it's
pretty populist which is not necessarily
in a very libertarian directional other
big exceptions on regulation and on the
left you is just going straight Bernie
Sanders here on economic policy which is
very hostile to a lot of issues of
economic freedom what what happened to
the Liberty movement or are we are we
thinking too much in terms of
high-profile national politics well
there's always been a strain of
nationalism within parts of the Liberty
movement there was in some sense an
alliance between libertarians and some
people who had more nationalistic views
whether on economics or other issues
against the establishment so they
allied themselves against the
establishment and now that you have a
president Trump who's very clearly in
one of the camps there many people who
were part of the Liberty Liberty
movement but we're more on the
nationalistic side now I don't want
anything to do with the libertarian part
of that movement and I think that's
caused some friction and maybe it's time
for people in the Liberty movement to
rethink some of those alliances think
about some of the principles that we
hold we believe in free markets we
believe in people being allowed to trade
and live with whoever they like and we
don't need the sort of nationalistic
side of it undermining those principles
because they're in conflict and if you
look back on people like von Mises or
Hayek or others they spoke very
negatively about this nationalist
strain they didn't like the idea of
nationalism in a country they thought it
was a very bad idea and dangerous to
Liberty on your Twitter feed you have
pinned George Washington quote warming
about parties and factions I've seen
over the last month you've had events
with a couple of high profile Democrats
and libertarian leading loved ones to be
sure jared Polis and and bethe well
Roark
what are you doing you go in rug what do
you what are you doing here I think the
parties are a problem that became more
clear to me when I entered Congress and
now have been in Congress for a few
years I can see that a lot of the the
inability to move forward on more
libertarian ideas is because we have
this two-party system that really
controls all of the levers and you have
a Republican leadership that basically
decides all of the outcomes in advance
and doesn't allow issues to be debated
on the floor and I believe that a lot of
these libertarian views would be
successful in a floor vote if they were
allowed to be debated but we don't have
that opportunity under this leadership
team and you're not going to get that
opportunity under Democratic leadership
so it's not that the parties are
problematic because bipartisanship is
is a cure-all and it's the greatest
thing in the world there's a lot of bad
things that happen through
bipartisanship in fact many of the worst
pieces of legislation passed with
overwhelming bipartisan majorities so
it's not a call for bipartisanship it's
a call for non-partisanship I think that
we need to move away from this idea that
you just have two parties who are at war
with each other and one party is good
and the other party is evil because that
leads to all sorts of bad outcomes
you get end justifies the means of
thinking and just about everything and
liberty doesn't really have an
opportunity to flourish and in that sort
of environment so what do you do I mean
you can nonpartisan your own brain but
you're still a Republican still in the
system is still like this what can you
do tangibly to further that kind of goal
or ethos well I'll keep speaking about
it for one thing I speak to young people
all the time and try to encourage them
not to be beholden to these two parties
they don't have to be a Republican or
Democrat they can be something else
right now I I would say that the largest
group out there are independent people
people who aren't aligned with one of
the two parties so we need to make sure
that the next generation is thinking
about this and hopefully over time these
two parties start to fall apart they're
getting smaller each year which is why I
think the partisan rhetoric is getting
elevated because they're actually
smaller and smaller each year and
they're becoming more extreme just to
make sure you know you just said you're
Republican advocating for the Republican
Party to fall apart well I think over
time that's what has to happen I think
both parties not just the Republican
Party I think the Democratic Party as
well I don't think that in the modern
era you need this sort of
institutionalized party system to run
for office back when you didn't have an
Internet it made more sense people
didn't even know who they were voting
for they didn't meet the people they
couldn't hear about the particular
individuals views so they had to depend
on the party system to tell them who to
vote for and in and in this day and age
you don't need that I can go straight to
Twitter or Facebook or elsewhere
and tell people exactly what I stand for
and and young people I think understand
that better than our generation and
older generations so I think there's an
opportunity to really have a paradigm
shift here but it might not happen in
the near future it might be the next
generation that has to do that
all right well will that we'll leave it
there thank you very much for joining us
thanks for reason I'm Matt Welch
[Music]